- Depuis quelques jo
les acheteurs d'armes se ruent
dans les magasins.
PIERRE PHARAND, propriétaire
Club de tir de l'Outaouais
- Normalement, on a une réserve
comme n'impoquququel commerçant
garde les stocks. Là,
la réserve, elle est vendue
au complet. Fait qu'il n'y a
plus de stock, fait que ce qu'il
reste, c'est dans les vitrines,
puis c'est tout. Puis ça,
c'est en deux jours.
- Partout au Québec, la nouvelle
mouture du projet de loi C-21
sur les armes à feu pousse
les amateurs à se procurer
une arme.
PIERRE PHARAND, copropriétaire,
Club de tir de l'Outaouais
- Je peux vous dire que,
pour le moment, je pense que
Justin Trudeau, c'est
le meilleur eueueur d'armes
que j'ai eu depuis 13 ans.
- Lundi dernier, Ottawa
a annoncé un gel national
de la vente, l'achat
et le transfert des armes
de pu u u u pays
d'ici l'automne.
Seuls les tireurs qui ont déjà
une arme pourront la conserver.
- Mes seuls clients qui vont
me faire vivre, c'est ceux
qui en ont présentement.
- Contrairement
aux États-Unis,lalalala réglemet
le possession d'une arme
de poing est stricte.
Une pratique règlementée
qui ne se déploie
qu'exclusivement dans les club
de tir.
C'est toute une industrie
qui est en péril.
- C'est sûr et certain qu'on
n'aura plus de nx x x x tireurs
parce qu'ils ne seront plus
capables d'avoir des armes,
donc l'entreprise va s'en aller
en décroissance. Moi, j'ai
investi avec trois partenaires
1,3 millions il y a 13 ans.
Je ne vois pas ça de tnnnnn
augure ce qui se passe
présentement.
- L'objectif du gouvernementdedn
de la violence par arme à feu,
des experts croient qu'il manque
sa cible en s'attaquant
aux armes de poing.
- Évidemment, ces armes-là
peuvent être volées, détournés
vers des fins criminelles. Ceci
étant dit, ce que tous les corps
de police au Canada disent,
c'est que l'essentiel des armes
qui sont retrouvées sur
les scènes de crime
dans les rues des grandes villes
canadiennes proviennent du sud
de la frontière.
- Agissons pour réduire
la criminalité, dit Éric,
en évitant de punir les amateurs
légitimes."
- C'est de donner des ressources
aux policiers, leur contrôle
aux frontières, c'est toujours
ça. C'est du travail de rue
que ça prend. Ils en donnent,
mais c'est parce que,
politiquement, c'est pas payant.
- Toute l'industrie espèrequ'Otl
d'épaule.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau
Radio-Canada, Montréa